OUT AND I DO NOTTROM A
STOP.
SAVE MADE OFF OF THE BLOCKER.
THE PUCK, BACK TO
>> Rick: TIPPED IN FRONT, DUBE T
GOAL BUT MONAHAN
RIGHT THERE TOO!
[ Horn ]
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> Kelly: GIBSON, HE KNEW IT WAS
COMING, LOOKING TO SEAL
STOPPING HENRIQUE, TWICE!
WITH THEN FRONT AND OFF OF
THE SIDEE CIRCLE.
SHOT!
OFF OF THE POST, BEATING
SONNY MILANO!
GETTING ANAHEIM ON THE BOARD TO
CUT THE
FORECHECKERS AND LUNDESTROM, ANG
THAT REBOUND AWAY AND THAT WOULD
HAVE FOR LINDHOLM.
AND THAT MAKES IT 3-1,HE SKATES.
AND THEN GUESS WHAT?POWER-PLAY T
4-1, CALGARY! 4-1 LEAD FROM LIN.
AND IT IS
CENTRE.
NOW GAUDREAU, IN FRONT! ACROSS,D
STOLARZ A FINE SAVE OFF OF
COLEMAN, COLEMAN A TIP, THEN TH.
HE DOVE ACROSS!
HE REBOUND.
A GOOD, SMART PLAY.
THIS IS MARKSTROM AND
ISAC LUNC YOUNG
PLAYER, RIGHT HERE, HEAD U TIME.
KYLINGTON, WITH IT.
PLAYED IN FRONT LINE, DESLAURIE.
THE FLAMES NOW BAC STOPPED
BY STOLARZ AND IT IS AND HE SAY,
I BET LINDHOLM AND SHOT, THEY
SCORE!
MANGIAPANE G G THE NET AND